all right movies in San Diego Comic-Con
2023. put your hands together and make
some noise we're about to watch Batman
Beyond with Kevin Smith and Mark Bernard
[Music]
well looks like they got stuck on the
street so we'll try it again
all right guys make some noise again for
Kevin Smith and Mark Bernard next time
all right
hey
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernardin hey
kids welcome to Comic-Con 2023 man has
everyone been having a good con
lovely me and Mark we're just uh
backstage upstairs
um which sounds like the title of our
new TV show backstage upstairs
um and we were uh discussing
the moment appreciating the moment uh
something that is uh sometimes difficult
to do because we're always when I say we
I'm always [__] busy creating the
next thing to do the next thing to do
the next thing to do until I'm in the
thing that I created a few months ago
and in that moment and sometimes in the
moment you forget to appreciate it
because you're on your way to the next
[__] thing but I said to mark
I'm gonna slow down on this show and
appreciate the fact that it's Comic-Con
2023 and it's going to be over before I
know it so just for the next hour kids
we're going to kick back and appreciate
the fact that we're all [__] alive
and we're all here to celebrate the
popular Arts we're all here for [__]
passion in order to do that we're going
to get drunk in doing so
I feel like I'm somewhat responsible for
your new I'm getting drunk
when I wind up in a rehab
milk was good
I quit the weed and now this I did I
bunk it six months of that weed and now
I'm like booze there's the answer
uh we are here at the movies pop-up at
the Tin Roof Inn in San Diego give it up
for the good folks continue to win
got Batman himself JC is here
bam
Dr Josh rash on the Wheels of Steel
shooting let's give it up for Dr Josh
Rouse
what what is he a doctor of
Divinity there it is
um so I expressed the notion of like uh
right before we went there like what do
you want to drink and I was like you
know what like do they have pina coladas
and the most excited I've ever seen Josh
in his life was like yes let's get you
drunk I want to see that they didn't
have pina coladas what am I drinking
strawberry hurricane uh I asked for the
uh fruitiest drink they have let's see
how it goes down
can I get a straw
uh that was lovely so I asked them to
set up three so I'd have to wait for
[__] drinks and I could just [__]
feed the need as we go along oh what are
you drinking I got my ties
what's in that uh boost
but they're like what do you want to
drink it's like I'm good with water
because like three fruity lady drinks
and I'm like then three for me as well
set them up I'll keep
to your kids you sold us out in record
time for this show thank you so much
how has your Comic-Con been thus far
this is the first time I've seen you I
know this time uh it has been the most
wonderful con I've ever had in my entire
life [__] a give it up for that man
and I'll tell you why tell us because we
got to screen Splinter last night
um the short film that I made with the
help I'm assuming of some of you good
people who may or may not have
contributed to the kickstarter
um it felt like the natural full circle
of of making that short is bringing it
back to Comic-Con like the place that
has built and stoked so much nerd dreams
in my own heart right and the desire to
interact with the culture that I love
and then be a part of making the culture
that I love and then to bring the
culture that I made to this place like
it was it was so wonderful and I you
know me like when we first launched the
kickstarter I was like Kevin I'm gonna
have to put in my own money to make this
happen you're like no you won't I was
like you're gonna put in the money no I
won't yeah I was like [__] that
I won't even pay for my own art why
would I pay for yours and he was like no
like the the fan base the people will
will show up like and I didn't believe
it until they showed up you showed up in
record numbers and then I also was like
well we're going to screen at the
comment at 7 30 on a Thursday it's day
one
nobody's gonna come it's late people's
gonna be at a [__] partying already
it's like it's a 300 seat room it's like
it's gonna be me and 12 people and we'll
just [__] play UNO together
skip
reverse draw Thor
and uh and it was a packed house there
were like three empty seats we screened
the short at the top and it was a
standing ovation
um which I took no pictures of because I
was too busy crying because it was such
a beautiful moment I know right and this
this is a man who doesn't really [__]
cry he just hates this
so to reach him emotionally man it took
a lot yeah and uh and friend of the
podcast Dave desmulchin Dan was there he
was my moderator for said podcast that's
right we talked about that last time his
birthday is coming up I think it's today
or today or tomorrow yeah happy birthday
celebrate the small chip man very much
so and he's here promoting his comic
book He's promoting his independent film
that was not produced by or funded by
any uh corporate entity uh late night
with the devil yes which we talked about
on a previous episode is absolutely
wonderful if you get a chance to see it
when it's finally available somewhere
see late night with the devil streaming
tomorrow night here at the convention
seriously yeah like go to his Instagram
and you'll see the all those but it's
yeah tomorrow night at like 10 p.m
somewhere in the gas line so go if
you're here go if you're at home sorry
you can see
um what was that what was it like
after the panel was done like in the
moment it's all adrenaline and all joy
and [__] when it's all over is that when
you had the moment to reflect to be like
holy [__] I did it I mean it's it's it's
all gratitude right it's all like all of
these people help me make a thing the
people who are on the stage with me my
actors my producers my my department
heads everybody in the crowd everybody
on the internet like it's just deep deep
gratitude for helping me do a thing for
helping me make a dream come true and
that remains my feeling about it like
every time I get to talk about it every
time I get to go to festival with it it
is all just thanks everybody for showing
up because I was never sure anybody
would the um that's beautiful give it up
for Mark
thank God they lined up free because I'm
done with one holy [__]
um the uh I need a straw too apparently
yes it helps it go faster fight with his
ice all day
um I have had a wonderful con uh We've
this is the second year in a row that
we've set up the movies pop up uh that
Tin Roof Inn has become a wonderful home
for us it affords us the ability to do
shows here as well
but this is the con where
um I turned into Mr Potato Head they did
a pop Tater of me so it's Silent Bob Mr
Potato Head I knew that was coming and I
knew that was a I was describing it
today uh thusly
um to Captain ripman
um John sprinklemeyer with whom I do the
Masquerade book and he's done covers for
quick stops and stuff uh he did the Jay
and Silent Bob secret stash logo he did
my fat man logo years ago
uh I try to organize Life as a cascading
Joy machine for myself which is like I
start things and put them in motion and
then start another thing put in a motion
start things and put it in motion and
the thing I started like eight ten
months ago like you see it you approve
it and then you're moving on to the next
thing and you won't see it for like
eight to ten months or a year or
something like that and then one day it
just falls into your lap
creates This Joy we're like oh my God I
remember approving this I remember
working on this and it's an existing
thing it's here now and so I had that
moment a few times number one uh
Roosevelt's did this like beautiful
[__] blunt man and chronic
button-down shirt which we're selling at
our movies pop-up store I got to see
that in person it's [__] fantastic
and I remember months ago approving the
design and being like can my nose be
smaller
there it is it exists same thing with
the pop Tater I remember like they sent
me a picture of it and then I said they
sent me one of them like in New Jersey
so I actually saw it and stuff and then
it's for sale here on the con floor but
the thing that I forgot didn't forget
but was just like I approved it went
through every one of the [__]
drawings and was like delighted by it
but it was months ago and now it's come
into fruition and is probably the item
that is defined Comic-Con 2023 for me is
Garbage Pail Kids did a yeah to toss one
of those over did a a what do they call
a collab
with us and so they did a view of skew
Universe set of Garbage Pail Kids and so
there's tons of artwork of all the
characters I created done Garbage Pail
Kids style and as much as I enjoyed it
as much as like people have been like oh
my God you're a garbage pail kid now and
[__]
um Jason Muse
who has been standing next to me
personally and professionally for the
last 30 [__] years and stuff and is
in newer to like most of the things that
happened to us just blithely and
different the cascading Joy machine for
him is completely different than mine
and he loves seeing like us be toys and
[__]
but this profoundly impacted him when he
saw this he got glassy-eyed
and he was just like this is a higher
honor than when we put our feet in the
cement at that place
and I was like Roman's Chinese Theater
he goes this is my groman's Chinese
Theater he was like I collected these as
a [__] kid and seeing himself as a
garbage pail kid like put such joy into
his face the only thing that will make
him as happy I think is he keeps talking
about it and I used to think it was a
joke but apparently it's serious he's
like we need to be wax figures at that
place
and I'm like Madame Tussauds and he's
like yes that's one I'll know we've made
it but he's like until then this is the
surest sign that we [__] made it
watching the joy in his face alone and
watching the internet light up about
this internet is a wonderful place for
me but it's also fraught with Peril
that's where people can come at me and
stuff but they also largely by and large
come at me with joy this seems to have
created so much [__] joy as joyful as
it was as joyful as it was for me to see
the drawings and approve them and be
like yeah those names are funny and [__]
like that having people interact with it
and react to it online has been
absolutely [__] wonderful so this is
Khan 2023 for me that and also we did a
panel
last night or Masters of the Universe
which was absolutely [__] wonderful I
I begged off of doing a Hall age show
this year and that was before like the
strikes and stuff like that every year
they they're very gracious at Comic-Con
International and they're always like uh
Hey man write up a thing for your panel
for your whole age whatever you want to
call it this year and you know I went
through a thing this year and my mental
health thing and stuff and so normally
doing Hall age for me is a joy but it's
also this weird moment where a lot of my
self-worth comes from external forces I
can't validate myself I need an audience
obviously and so Hall h is this weird
moment for me where like if it's not
packed like I'm always like oh my God
I'm irrelevant and it's all over and
[__] like that and so I usually follow
the Marvel panel and the marble panel is
the definition of a packed tall age and
then they're like you know stick around
next for Kevin Smith and like [__]
half the audience leaves or something
like that or in the year of J.J Abrams
all the audience [__] rules so
there's always this moment where like I
can't wait to do all age but at the same
time I'm like what if I get up there and
[__] seats are empty and blah blah
blah so this year I wanted to spare
myself from that and I was like I don't
really have anything to promote so I'm
going to take this year off of hall h
and so I told the folks at Comic-Con a
few months ago like yeah I'm gonna skip
all H this year leave it for better
people than I was like I've got the
movies pop up and stuff so I know I'll
I'll be there with an audience and
that'll be fine
um so sag struck and every person that
normally goes to Hall age is not at Hall
age
I would have been the biggest [__]
thing in the whole age
if I've just done the [__] path as it
stands because there are no [__]
actors here you and me may be the most
famous people at [__] Comic-Con right
now
[Music]
when do I get the free [__] that famous
people get
a good question I'm still waiting for it
myself and [__] but [__] I got these
and that's what matters
um before we go further kids we have a
sponsor we should shout them out uh the
good Folks at Emmy eats
.com are our sponsors tonight and for
those of you who are like what's that
Emmy makes ramen noodles uh and they
make them for people not just like me
but definitely people like me they're
vegan as [__]
and when I went vegan I had to say
goodbye to Ramen noodles and [__]
because they're not but now [__]
thanks the good folks of Emmy they are
man they're low carb they're high
protein
but they're they're [__] tasty
um I they sent me a free box and my kid
was over the house and she was like
what's this and I was like this is Emmy
they do these ramen noodles that I'm
gonna do a commercial for and [__]
she took in all the best flavors and
left me with this [__] shrimp which I
never even ate shrimp when I was not a
vegan and stuff like that but so I ate
the [__] shrimp and even that was
[__] good man emmyeats.com I m m l i
i m m i e a t s.com slash fat man is the
address to go to or you just go to
emmyeats.com and use the code fat man
they're giving you five bucks off man
that's emmyeats.com Fatman to get five
bucks off this [__] is legit [__]
wonderful man um it's a perfect low carb
snack it's got a lot of [__] protein
if uh if if you're one of those people
it's like I gotta eat some [__] on the
go it just reminds me of [__] eating
ramen noodles when I was a kid man like
we were a poor [__] family so my mom
would buy stacks of this [__] [__]
and that was like what sustained me
through most of my youth it tastes like
a happy [__] childhood that's the
best review I could [__] give it take
over I'm gonna get drunk
turns out my childhood was not that
happy apparently
uh like each packet has only 5G of net
carbs keeping lean and active getting
more protein in your diet with this [__]
with 22 grams of protein three times
more than traditional Brands it's a
perfect pre or post-workout meal and hey
if you want to stay in shape with a
delicious comforting bowl that tastes
way better than those planned protein
shakes boom me eats 300 calories and 85
percent less net carbs than normal
instant Ramen which I grew up eating and
stuff so you can eat it guilt-free
improves your gut health
because it has uh Jesus 18 grams of
fiber in it you're gonna [__] bricks
kids
and he will make you [__] there's the
best [__] slogan I could possibly
build a house with your own feces
so try it out man help us out go to
emmyeats.com
i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s.com slash fat man uh I
think you're gonna get five bucks off
your first [__] order uh give them a
shot I I absolutely love it that's not
me just saying [__] and whatnot that's
me legitimately eating this [__] and
love it and my kid who's finicky like
Morris the [__] cat she [__] loves
it as well that's a deep Cuts reference
um our childhood oh [__] even you it
took you a second uh it works damn good
[__] emmyeats.com Fatman we thank the
good Folks at Mees for sponsoring this
night's episode put your hands together
for Emmy eats again
okay business is out of the way let's do
pleasure man what can we talk about at
Comic-Con first off
let's acknowledge the fact that there's
a strike going on you're striking for
the writer's Guild I remember the
Writers Guild of America I'm striking
for yes
and you've been striking and I've been
striking with you as a writer skilled
member for what close to 80 days at this
point over 80 Days uh some 12 maybe 13
weeks I don't know how math Works
um but but coming to Comic-Con and
especially for the actors it's been
about what can we promote what can we
talk about
um cassag joined the [__] fight they
did last time we did a show had they
joined it or they were they had they
were on the verge of it and so since
then the 160
000 member strong Screen Actors Guild
also went on strike for many of the same
reasons for protections against AI for
increased transparency of residuals and
streaming numbers and and just like
basic human decency and so that's why
we're all on strike and there are rules
from what we can talk about Comic-Con
was a little bit fraught with can you
promote things can you even appear can
you do panels
um can we be journalists can we be quite
influencers we've never influenced
anybody did you do anything ever right
but whatever and except eat me eats yes
yes get your cup man we need sponsors
bring your balls clean
and uh and so a lot of it is what's the
spirit of the strike why are we striking
what will help the cause and a lot of it
is like not shouting out not promoting
the work from people who have not kind
of respected us as as sort of
collaborators we had a conversation this
week a text conversation where Mark was
like we can't talk about movies or
movies or TV shows because of the SAG
strike because the Writers Guild strike
but then you gotta follow-up thing that
said yeah I was saying that like we're
not according to sec we're not
prohibiting journalists from doing their
job and I'm like well I've never turned
in my press card it's still in my fancy
hat in my closet yes and so like I am
still a journalist which means I can
still talk about movies I've seen and
shows that I've liked and I mean less
trailers because that is just straighter
promotional so it won't be covering
right let me [__] the kid on the Pike
but we can still do a show uh and we can
still talk about why we like the things
we like or in some cases why we don't
um yeah
what
I was gonna say there's only threat of
one of us doing that oh mister I really
love the Flash
I I saw it four times I know you're the
only one I think so at the end of the
day
you saw it as well that many times yeah
I own it you own it you bought it
already Michael Keaton that's what I was
I was saying
I bought it and I hate it who runs our
website one night and put together the
movies pop-up uh the sales experience
and whatnot
um Luke's a big DC movie kid and he
didn't catch it the flash when it was in
theaters because it went fast
um but he [__] with it recently on
video and was
more in your Camp very I mean beyond
your Camp he was like what the [__]
but I was like you gotta get to the
Michael Keaton part if you got the
Michael Keaton he's like not yet and
he's like I was just so dispirited by
the whole thing I didn't get that far I
was like get to Michael Keaton that's
where the movie becomes a movie for me
seeing him as Batman again was [__]
everything and whatnot but he was give
it up for [__] Michael T sadly
look I'm not gonna lament what we're
gonna miss going forward not having
Michael Keaton play Batman again because
like [__] a year ago two years ago I
was like Michael Keaton's gonna be
everything in the [__] DC Universe
from now on and now we just have this
one bite at the Apple but seeing my
[__] Batman and don't get me wrong I
love bat Fleck and whatnot like
literally love that flick but seeing
Michael Keaton put on the suit and be
like how much do you weigh and [__] like
that really [__] did it for me so I
know a lot of people are like [__] The
Flash but I'm like well but don't [__]
Michael Keaton Batman or or do but but
don't [__]
so yes I did I'm not gonna take a bullet
for liking that movie and [__] I already
take enough [__] online for people for
that that being said the flash was not
the movie of the summer
um
the mission impossible didn't turn out
to be the movie of The Summer yeah as we
sit here and speak right now though
based on the Articles I've seen and
whatnot the movie of the summer is
[__] Barbie apparently how many
people have seen Barbie so far well it's
opening tonight that one right there
well it opened last night and did
[__] like 23 million dollars in
Thursday night previews which is more
than any movie has [__] done they
were like articles all over about that's
more than the Batman that's more than
[__] Guardians of the Galaxy that's
more than across the spider-verse they
are projecting the Barbie movie to make
130 million dollars this weekend now
you may be like what the [__] does this
have to do with you I am now not just a
filmmaker and [__] with no skin in the
Barbie game but I'm a film exhibitor I
own a movie theater called smodcast
Castle Cinemas it has been a [__]
lean summer The Flash was in and out of
our theaters in eight [__] days like
Ernie earnings podcast keeper Ernie
O'Donnell who runs the theater had to
let it go I was like why do you let it
go for tonight for two weeks he's like
nobody is [__] coming uh Mission
Impossible was supposed to be the movie
that saved the summer and it opened okay
did Less business than the last one
opened at so as a film exhibitor man
like where what you count on is selling
popcorn and [__] soda and in order to
do that you need people to come to the
movies
Ernie sent me a [__] photo today of a
line down the block
people for [__] both Barbie and
Oppenheimer
and I know we're not supposed to be
excused and that would be Warner Bros
and who puts out Oppenheimer Universal
Universal but that's not me talking as a
sag member this is me talking as a film
exhibitor a member of NATO the National
Association of theater owners
he's immobilize you guys yes this is
[__] absolutely man we're a member of
NATO now it makes people real scared
when you say it [__] then when you say
what it is they're like oh
can I have popcorn for this water yes
they those two movies have have saved
summer 2023 has an exhibitor as a
filmmaker I got no skin in the game as a
film fan sometimes you got you don't
have skin in the game but you have an
opinion or something like that but as
somebody who whose business lives and
dies by movies that people actually want
to come see having those two movies come
out this weekend at the same [__]
time and I know there was you know a lot
of fun online about Opera Barbie and
[__] like that which movie will do
better they're battling head to head and
[__] to have both movies do insanely
well Barbie's going to open 130 million
but it looks like Oppenheimer is going
to open over 50 million and that's a
[__] three hour movie about a guy who
made the nuclear [__] bomb that is
[__] awesome for movie going man like
as a guy who owns a theater that's
[__] everything now I'll put my sag
hat back on [__] the studios
how dare they do a thing but also I've
had people ask me online like what can
we do to support the strikes should we
stop going to movies and I'm always like
no don't do that because that will hurt
people who own movie theaters who were
not striking against we have nothing we
have no beef with them you're not paying
my residuals you're not in charge of AI
That's skymet apparently yes and so like
if you'd like to support like there's
lots of ways to do it just social
amplification helping explain to your
family why we're on strike like I did an
interview with NPR Illinois talking
about it well there's an explained to
Middle America why we should give a [__]
and so I spent 45 minutes explaining to
Middle America why to give a [__] here's
a great opportunity to explain like the
internet when sag went on strike there
was a lot of people a lot of folks on
the internet are like folk the
billionaires want more money and [__]
the sac fight is really not about the
Tom cruises of this world which is why
Tom Cruise doesn't walk the [__]
picket line and [__] who it's about are
the people the actors in Sag who can
barely make twenty six thousand dollars
a year to cover their [__] medical
coverage to get their medical bills and
[__] because the business has shrunk in
such ways in terms of what they pay out
and the business model has changed there
was a time where you could do a TV show
and collect residuals up until the time
you were 80 [__] years old and [__]
and the checks get smaller and smaller
there's a bar in Los Angeles called
residuals that on the wall has a series
of checks for like [__] residual
checks as they get more and more
ridiculous like one cent and [__] like
that that used to be like the unnormal
aspect of it like this is cute that is
now the [__] Norm if you're actor on
a [__] uh streaming show that's what
your check looks like there was a it was
an actress on um or an actor she's the
New Black Orange is the New Black who
put up what who is it what's the
person's name
put up her
residual checks that she made and it was
like all in like twelve dollars or
something I think it was 28 [__]
dollars for a show that the entire world
has watched which is Orange is the New
Black and so that has everything to do
with like the model that came together
because of the streaming world and
streaming worlds created new
opportunities for actors there's Thrice
four times five times as many shows as
there used to be but because of the deal
they made eons ago the structure of
residuals doesn't exist like it used to
do you want to show not even a hit TV
show you could live off that later on it
could pay for your medical coverage as
long as you made like 26k a year or
something like that most of the folks
who are in Sag aren't able to hit that
anymore so for all the folks online who
are like uh millionaires billionaires
wanting more money it's literally not
about that it is about the working actor
who can't [__] make ends meet a lot
of people on these streaming shows that
are successful are talking about now
coming out and being honest about like I
have a literally two other [__] jobs
even though I'm on a hit [__] show in
order to make my rent in New York or
something New York a very expensive
place to live but some cats have to live
there same in Los Angeles some cats have
to live in Los Angeles in order to be in
these things but it's a costly city to
live so the SAG fight isn't about
[__] rich people getting richer man
it's about people who are choosing
for their for their vocation in life
their calling is to self-express in in
major Ways by getting dialogue and in
minor Ways by just being in the
background and background artists are
threatened by the fact that the studio
is put forward a deal where it's like if
you're in a Thing Once We own your image
in perpetuity and we get to use it
anywhere we [__] want which is a
[__] crime it's like stealing
somebody's image and like because of
[__] Ai and CG they could just use
them over and over again instead of
paying them each time they show up to
work and it's not like for a million
dollars we will take your life rights
it's for a hundred dollars we will scan
your body in your face and we can put
you in anything despite your own
philosophical obligations to that or
objections to that do you not want to be
in a horror movie [__] you you're going
to be in a horror movie now you don't
want to be in pornography [__] you
you're gonna take one of the face
because we have
your face wait I didn't know that was a
possibility everything is signing up for
that [__] nothing is forbidden that's
true that could put you in the crowd
scene of a porno yeah where you're just
cooking it out from the side
and there's no rules about what they can
and can't do to your face they can
change your [__] clothes that means
they could put an arm on you going like
this and [__] you could be doing things
that you wouldn't even intend to do with
your performance so that's what the SAG
fight is about kids it's not about like
people rich people getting richer and
stuff
um that's the very cynical approach to
the argument and trust me people of the
level of like Tom Cruise aren't sitting
there going like I want more and [__]
let them eat cake this is about people
who can't even [__] cake man they can't
even afford meeats.com
thank you very much
what's up my friend well it's also I
don't know if you saw Fran Drescher drop
the uh Bob Iger makes 78 000 a day
per day so it's not like they're
fighting for money that would come out
of all of our pockets they're fighting
for money that's going to be coming out
of
very very much richer people's pockets
right yeah I mean those richer people
big argument is like those rich people
don't create anything yes they don't
create anything except they create
wealth for shareholders and that's why
the shareholders reward people like that
with exorbitant [__] salaries because
it's like you made me more money but
that making me more money means somebody
else got screwed out of [__] money
and it's like look I applaud your
ability to make your shareholders more
money but not at the expense of people
actually create this [__] [__] and
put asses in seats and it's like whether
you're writing a thing and in charge of
it whether in the background of a
[__] thing it's a collective creative
effort and those those people should
feel and and receive proper remuneration
for for the efforts they're putting in
absolutely
yeah
this was my third that's my fourth yes
you've won more truth is coming kids
next I'll tell you what I really think
about Netflix
[Applause]
yeah and it is it is always uh to me
personally that anybody would choose the
side of the faceless Corporation against
the poor Working Man and poor I'm
putting in quotes but still to your
point lots of people here who were not
barely middle class yeah we're just
doing this because they love it they do
it because it's art and they want to
make art and the writer's Guild you know
even to put a number on the writers goes
looking for two percent of the annual
profits of these giant streamers and a
billion dollars is hard to [__] wrap
your head around like it sounds like
it's a number whatever but like a
million seconds
is like four months right a billion
seconds is 30 years
and so if they're making 40 billion
dollars a year and we want over three
years 400 million that's nothing to them
for one person yes everybody yes it's
for everybody and meanwhile there's
dudes making 400 million dollars a year
uh one guy and so it is it is about
balance it's about being able to
participate in the engines of your own
success and that's ultimately it and
deciding you want to like saddle up
inside with the faceless megacorp
and not the people who make the [__] you
love it's it's a weird decision it is at
the end of the day but um [__] I'm drunk
the uh
anyway yeah
um enough uh kind of enough strike talk
uh it will never be done talking until
it's done I will I do want to shout out
like you know Bob Iger when the SAG
strike uh kicked off
like just [__] put his foot right in
his mouth by going like I don't
understand these people man they're
being unrealistic and [__] like that
um Ted sarandos who's the the guy at
Netflix actually like put out a really
human statement or talked about some I
don't know if it was a statement or an
interview but he talked about he's like
look I grew up in a union household my
father was a union member an electrician
blah blah blah and he's the guy going
like I want to solve this as quickly as
possible I want to go to the table and I
want to make it work so there are people
who who see and understand like just
because you work at a giant mega
Corporation and [__] doesn't mean you're
like you know let him eat [__] cake
and stuff they understand that they need
artists in order to [__] do what they
do you can't collect that giant [__]
bonus paycheck for making shareholders a
bunch of money unless you have something
people want to [__] watch and in
order to have something people want to
watch writers have to go back to work
actors have to go back to work so
hopefully the strike ends sooner rather
than later now I saw because yes you
know give it up for that one guy
I was on a um talk about like [__] as
much as like I support the writer's
Guild I was on a panel for Masters of
the Universe yesterday and there were a
few Cats online who were like aren't you
a [__] striking writer shouldn't you
be outside striking against uh Netflix
and [__] like that here's the sad truth
animation writers not part of the wga by
and large no yeah tell them why Mark
[__] I was saying this backstage Mark
and he told me this history and I was
like I didn't [__] know that tell
them why people that write largely
people that write animation aren't a
part of the writer's Guild
um yeah the the animation Guild which is
a part of biatsi which is part of like
you know the sort of electricians and
the and most of the crew members who
work on a set are part of iatse which is
an incredibly strong union they seem
they're standing by our side in
solidarity
but the reason that exists is because
back in the 30s or whatever when Walt
Disney was beginning to to increase its
output The Writers Guild of America then
someone new but still you know gaining
strength wanted the animation writers
under their [__] auspices and while
Disney was like no what if what if I
start a guild that you all are members
of and I'll kind of take care of you and
it'll be fine everybody well that sounds
like an amazing charitable thing you're
the best person in the world Walt Disney
nothing problematic whatsoever and
ultimately what happened was they ended
up folding into a union in which the
animation writers are
like very high minority like there's not
a ton of Animation writers in that
massive Union and so they have no
collective bargaining power they will
never go on strike they can never do
what we're doing now which is force
people to take them seriously and so
they don't get residuals on the things
that they write their health care is
incredibly hard to get and not nearly as
robust their pension plan is not as
robust and they every day I talk to an
animation where I was like man I wish I
was in the wga because you guys have
power and you guys can strike and you
guys can fight for the people who do the
work
and it's unfortunate and every year
there is some Overture to try and wrap
our heads around it but then Disney
still doesn't want that Warner Brothers
still doesn't want that all the people
who are making cartoons in the 30s 40s
50s and 60s are like we like it the way
it is it's cheaper for us to do and it's
it's so desperately unfortunate but
that's why if you're writing a cartoon
you can pretty much talk about the work
that you did you could promote it
because that Guild is not on strike yeah
and the thing is like some people are
like well [__] it if you don't make a
lot of money as a cartoon writer don't
write [__] cartoons you don't write
cartoons against super wealthy you write
cartoons because you grew up watching
[__] cartoons
and as a child
the moment you realize like there was a
name attached to these things like you
know I watch [__] Looney Tunes till
I've still watch Looney Tunes and when I
was a kid
like the name Michael Maltese meant
something to me because I'm like I saw
that name over and over again and the
idea of like these are people that make
this like you wanted to be a part of
that fraternity sorority you wanted to
be a part of like the people who can do
right for a [__] cartoon I can't draw
for [__] if I could I wouldn't make all
these terrible movies people hate
I love them all thank you very much
um so does my mom but uh but I can write
I can put a few words together and [__]
and the idea of putting words together
and then handing it over to an animator
will turn it into something [__]
magical has always captured my
imagination so given the chance to write
animation even though you know my
[__] agent flat out told me like
you're gonna get rich doing this [__]
it's like I remember when I was first
writing comic books first time I got a
job writing Daredevil my agent at the
time scoffed at me and he was just like
what do you do what are you wasting your
time for he goes what do they pay you I
was like it's 200 a page he goes 200 a
page I'll get you like 200 000 to
rewrite a [__] script I was like I'm
not dealing this [__] for the money I'm
doing this [__] because I grew up
reading comic books and imagine what an
amazing [__] life it would be if I
could write that [__]
so same with animation working for
animation I've enjoyed my time on
Masters of the Universe I didn't do it
to get [__] Rich because I didn't get
[__] rich and that's not a complaint
because I knew going in what I was going
to be dealing with they told me up front
what I was going to make and [__] they
didn't tell me how much [__] I would
have to eat because of [__] the
animation that I did work on and stuff
but I worked on it because I grew up
watching [__] cartoons and the idea
of being an adult and I get to do this
[__] now I want to do that thing so yes
it's unfortunate that anime writers of
Animation aren't largely included in the
wga and that has everything to do with
good old [__] Walt Disney and [__]
like that but at the end of the day if
somebody told me going in like they did
tell me going in what I was gonna make
and what it was I didn't care I would do
this [__] for [__] free
um but I wish that as an animation
writer I was represented by the guild
but since I'm not I could sit on a panel
and [__] talk about the thing we did
and it's not just TV cartoons I mean if
you're in the and the animation Guild
and you write
[__] Toy Story
yeah you don't get residuals on that
that right yeah it's animation from
Disney you don't now Disney can decide
they run won't want to reward you break
you off a piece you know in the same way
that like George Lucas was like buying
[__] like here's your giant
check Mark Hamill for now it's a massive
success their contracts didn't say you
get five percent of gross revenue you
gave them a point you gave them a point
because he thought like this is the
Equitable thing to do
so Disney like I wrote Mulan great good
for you you don't actually get to keep
like the Lion's Share of the money that
that movie made the Lion King's share of
the money if you win what
dad joke that is that is two and a half
drinks in joke yes
um so some people don't get to celebrate
that Mulan money they do they don't you
know and so like unless Disney and
they're in their Grace and magnitude oh
like here you go person here's a bunch
of money thank you for all of your
service they don't have to do that they
might do it because they want to you
know we've had those conversations a lot
especially talking about people who
write comics and create say I don't know
a winter soldier and do not at all get
to take any Financial part of the
billion dollars that that character has
made and I'm like well what the [__]
like I it's I did this where's my taste
just be cool
you're asking people who hold on to the
money to be cool man it doesn't work
that way and then you know folks outside
go like well you work in TV and movies
it must be but you must you make more
money than the average person not in
every [__] case that's not true like
do you I'm not trying to create a fight
but do you remember what we got paid to
work on like Masters Universe I do tell
them
uh I think
script was like
ten ten thousand ten thousand five
hundred dollars I think is about what I
got paid to write a script
right now half of the internet is like
you were over [__] paid
but if I write a script of I don't know
let's say Castle Rock yeah uh or hey
let's not Castle Rock a show based in
the Stephen King connected Universe
which name I can't mention
good cover good cover let's say I don't
know a spaceship show that mayor man
don't use warp speed
I I get paid about 38
000 to write a live action episode of
television and it's the same job it's
the same word it's the same craft is I'm
trying to engineer in motion and plot
and and empathy out of words on a page
same [__] job I should not be getting
paid more to do one and less than to do
and that is entirely because one Guild
is strong and the other one is not and
can fight for me the other one won't
um or can't and it's I'm not gonna say
criminal It's just sad yeah you know and
like there was there was a writer who
was like I was a staff writer or or
story editor on the bear like one of the
most popular shows on TV it was like I'm
living paycheck to paycheck like and now
my paychecks have stopped because I want
to stay on the bear and the bear is a 10
episode show that goes every year and so
there's 10 months of the year I'm not
working
and all I made was this money on this
show and that's just not enough to
survive on it's like hey I made great I
made sixty thousand dollars living in
Los Angeles on one season of a show and
I can't do anything else for the rest of
the year and don't forget a percentage
of that goes to an agent the percentage
of that goes to a lawyer percentage of
that if you collect if you're lucky
enough to collect sixty thousand dollars
or something could put you in a tax
bracket where they take more of your
[__] money and stuff half that money
is going to somebody else thirty
thousand dollars over the course of a
year in Los Angeles
which is why they have nine roommates so
they build fake walls and they're living
stacked like on a naval carrier and why
they work on multiple things if you can
because if you're exclusive to a show
you can't take another job true so like
nobody asking for this money is Rich
nobody is looking nobody's a millionaire
looking to make billions everybody's
like I just want to pay my [__] rent
right I just want to be able to put a
kid through school I want to be able to
live the American dream and I'm so glad
and so happy and so honored to get to do
this work to get to write television and
make [__] up for money I just want it to
be more money
about literally every job yeah which is
true yeah that's why like unions are
such a big part of this country that's
why organized labor is so important
because and that's why we're fighting
against AI
right like it's
and AI is coming for everything you know
like go to a supermarket remember there
didn't used to be self-checkout lines
now there are maybe used to pay tolls by
like paying a person money that's gone
that's right there are jobs that are
disappearing now because of advances in
technology and artificial intelligence
or whatever that's it's going to come
for everybody every call center is going
to be like 80 computers that used to be
somebody's job yeah every bank teller
every bank is there but a shitload of
tellers now there's like four machines
and one person who's counting nickels
like
and so to to think that it's just us
complaining to think that it's just
artists and writers and actors or
whatever like if they crack this [__]
then like what happens to I don't know
college professors what happens to
teachers what happens to what happens to
like the kids who use AI to write term
papers how do you know if that kid knows
anything no it just that the fabric of
society needs some some safeguards some
[__] bumpers and some control and for
writers and actors we just want to be
the ones in control it's a tool
everything's a tool but don't put her in
the hands to the people who do not value
the people who make the Art Truth
all right enough about two tricks in
Fight the Power
uh let's talk about some [__] that would
have happened that Comic-Con had sag not
be striking the mo the Marvel panel
probably would have showcased the
Marvels probably but instead Marvel
Studios just dropped the Marvel's
trailer last night but we're not
supposed to talk about trailers not
talking electric so anyway that happened
I hope it was good I'm gonna put on my
not [__] sag Hatter writer's Guild
hat but just fan hat I saw the trailer
did you like that trailer it was a good
time man I mean it's kind of a version
of the first trailer they showed us but
with more villain this time around you
got to see more of the villain but it
looks like it's a fun time and God damn
if they're not milking that [__]
Beastie Boys remix for all it's worth
it better be in the [__] movie and
not just the trailer if not I will be
upset
um and they've got Nick Fury fun Nick
Fury in it funny Fury as opposed to the
fury who's on TV right now who's sad
Fury have you been watching still uh
since we talked about it I have not seen
another episode yeah not because I
didn't like it just like I'm just not
motivated to do it something huge
happened though again yeah I mean did
last time we talked about it they didn't
reveal the Avenger who was the squirrel
did they they did not no so spoilers
kids if you ever watch secret evasion
cover your ears and [__] but they
revealed that
spoilers three two okay am I allowed to
talk about and the whole [__]
internet's talking about it can't we
talk about it you can talk about it they
revealed that Roadie this whole time has
been a [__] scroll
I told you to cover your [__] ears
listen
five years ago this would have broke the
[__] internet listen All I'm gonna
say is there's like 48 white Avengers
do you know who the bad guy was just do
you think man
racial profiling thank you I haven't
even [__] processed that I'm so white
that never occurred to me I was like
he's gonna say Hawkeye he's gonna say
nobody likes
nope
so they took that from us everybody
um what uh what have you been watching
uh speaking of the bear the bear
um which everybody tells me I should be
watching here's why you should watch it
and I tried to explain to you last time
yes it is the best show I've ever seen
about the collaborative creative process
it is fundamentally about broken people
trying to figure out a purpose for their
own lives and how they find it in making
art and in the show that art happens to
be food and the way that they kind of
iterate and discover and reveal things
both about themselves and the art that
they're trying to make and how they
collaborate with each other and it's
like like being in a kitchen feels like
being in a writer's room in a way like
there's your head chef who thinks he
knows what he's doing but it's probably
[__] up there's your your CDC the chef
de cuisine who's like the person who's
got to actually get their [__] show
done there's your weird person in the
corner who's like really good at one
thing but awful at everything else
there's one person like chronically
underpaid but is doing all the work
anyway and then there's the the the
people dining or your audience who have
no idea what happened behind that wall
right but just love the food that comes
out and and specifically this episode if
you've seen the bear and you're caught
up on season two episode seven Forks
which is about the [__] you know
Richie the most dysfunctional character
on the show
learning to be good at a thing and
discovering what his life could be if he
only devoted himself to it it's
wonderful and heartbreaking and
enthusiastic and I watched that episode
like five times just to feel something
um gave up cutting did you I I did you
know like it was it was a whole thing
but my arms are thankful
but it is it's Ted lasso with a little
bit more grit but just as much like oh
this is what Humanity can do if we have
respect for each other and the product
we're making and it's glorious and it's
28 minutes an episode oh you just sold
it see I did it you guys
man everybody give it up for Jason
I I just want to give the world of this
room and the internet a quick
disclaimer that if you have worked in
the restaurant business or having to own
a restaurant
bragger the show is very PTSD it's a
hard watch
hurts you in ways that you didn't know
you could be hurt
hurt Jeff
all right so the bear is worth watching
the bear is worth watching uh what else
can we talk about I mean mentioned some
news very quickly things that have
happened in the world let's go
downstairs
can I share some some news some news
I've had too many whatever
you can share some news the uh the um we
did that Masters of the Universe panel
and we announced something I've known
forever and stuff but now the world
knows it what is it uh the voice of
hordak in our show because hordak is the
major part of uh Masters of the Universe
of evolution uh is being provided by the
amazing Keith David yes you get to hang
out with Keith David I've I've watched
him [__] work man and worked with him
never have I asked for so fewer takes
from somebody who just [__] Nails it
in the first [__] take and I gave him
a lot of alliterative dialogue and he
makes it work so beautifully
um and also making me wish that I worked
on season two right you missed out man I
could put words in the mouth [__]
Keith David can I still do it can I just
[__] like text you some [__] just
give me some lines for him to write
while the writer's Guild strike has
happened guys it's for my [__]
voicemail
um and also they at our panel we
announced that uh orko in the show was
gonna have a frenemy of sorts but we
couldn't say who it was during the panel
because they wanted to drive people to
the Mattel Booth to see they were like
when this panel's over we're gonna put
the action figure on display so you can
see who it is but until then you're
gonna have to go to the Mattel panel to
figure it out now word is out there in
the world so I could share it here you
remember Masters Universe movie yes
remember Billy Barney played a character
called Wilder yes that was supposed to
be Orco but they were like well this is
the closest we can get we [__] stole
gildor put him in our [__] show
you
[__] yes it's gonna be good
[__] times and the other thing I
announced on that panel which the
internet seemed amused by is we've
announced previously that William
Shatner has joined the show yes
um
the shot himself and so um Mark Hamill
of course plays our Skeletor as he did
in season one
um I talked about on the panel and then
I got yelled at afterwards but it's out
there already so [__] it I could talk
about it here we have a scene where
[__] William Shatner and and we have
a few Seas where William Shatner and
Mark Hamill act opposite one another so
finally Luke Skywalker and Captain Kirk
are [__] interacting
oh
my Force strong with this one yes
um okay do your [__] pithy news then
all right we got the flashy flashy light
so we're gonna Blaze through the [__]
um yeah Folks at home
um we're we're so limited in our time
here because at night the movies pop up
turns into movies after dark and a band
comes up on this very stage and the the
Tin Roof Inn goes back to like selling
booze uh and whatnot so it's a shorter
show but we're gonna go over because I'm
drunk and we have news
you gotta kick us out
uh so these are very good by the way
whatever the [__] these are what are
they called
hurricanes strawberry hurricanes I'm
[__] in my face is numb
it's a drag queen somewhere else in the
gas lamp whose name is strawberry
I remember there was going to be Orlando
Calrissian TV show yeah of course I
can't wait to watch it uh it's gonna be
a while for you to watch that show The
Red Hot Minute a red hot minute um is
Donald Glover so busy on other things uh
there is that but also Justin Simeon who
just released
um the the Haunted Mansion reboot movie
for Disney was the guy who was writing
and producing that show and he just did
an episode part of that press thing
which he could do as a director not as a
writer right uh talked about that uh you
know allegedly it's still happening but
he doesn't know when or if
uh he said I certainly poured my heart
and spent a lot of time working with
with Disney and lucasfilm to put
together a really great show it feels
like everybody loves it and as you know
we had to put a pause on it because of
scheduling and the next update he got
was in 2020 some years ago and I don't
know I have no idea what's going on with
it
Donald Glover in an interview with GQ
earlier this year was like I'd love to
play Lando again and it's a fun time to
be him it just needs the right way to do
it
um and he said that I'm not interested
in doing anything that's just going to
be a waste of my time or just a paycheck
I'd rather spend my time with people
that I enjoy so
I don't know yeah maybe like everybody
wants to do it but they don't know
exactly what that version of it is going
to be
um similarly John boyega who uh had had
his frictions with lucasfilm yes uh
during that sort of he's in something
that's dropping today by the way which
is a cloned Tyrone yes it's on a net
it's Netflix it's on the streamer that
we use name we shall not mention that
everybody has that most people that has
like better reviews than both Barbie and
Oppenheimer I read an article about it
yeah apparently it's amazing what is it
called they cloned Tyrone and it's him
Jamie Foxx Jazzy Bates and somebody and
uh Captain Marvel too
is that her name Tiana Parish yes
um so that's worth watching apparently
I'll be checking that out yeah but he
said that he's open to coming back to
Star Wars like he he had famously talked
about the lack of protection that he
felt while doing Force awakens and Rise
of Skywalker and and The Last Jedi both
for him and Kelly Marie Tran and the
internet who came to them for apparently
being Brown in Star Wars as a crime and
uh and so he was like listen that was a
few years ago but I'm open to characters
and scripts that are all enjoyable have
a great cast attention director so he
will happily return to the galaxy far
far away he also ranked the Star Wars
sequels in order and where did he land
um he said the force awakens was the
best then he put
um well I mean in terms of the three
that he was on oh yeah but still wrong
he would force awakens is the best he
put
um uh Revenge no what was the third one
called rise of Skywalker rise of
Skywalkers II and he said that last Jedi
was his least favorite wow I mean he's
wrong in almost every way
but I mean sure whatever hey John Boy
it's opinion it's just opinion it's just
a fact so there's not it's not possible
to have a wrong opinion until you have a
wrong opinion oh [__] Kevin listen we
don't have to
would be the fifth don't applaud this
[__]
when I need help in two years and [__]
where will you be
like hey welcome to Fan Man Beyond this
is a fundraiser for my new kidney
because it turned out that I became an
alcoholic
it's so easy all you had to do was put
sugar in the booze
um spam hey it's bamf man everybody give
it up for bands man
I may not be the right one to suggest
this but I have a little bit of a
experience with Star Wars
nobody knows what to do what about the
little experience a little uh maneuver
he pulled at the Battle of tanab right
don't we all want to see what he pulled
at the Battle it's an app make a show
about that
wait a way to White's blame one of the
only black characters in Star Wars but
yes you're absolutely right there's a
way to do it I'd like to believe that
what he would eat the battle tonight
I'mma [__] this robot you guys
[Applause]
uh and the last thing we'll hit quickly
because it happened I think just after
our last show is that uh apparently
there's a [__] ton of people in this new
Superman Legacy movie that James Gunn is
doing including a Green Lantern
including metamorpho including Mr
terrific and Hawkgirl are all going to
be in his Superman movie who's playing
them do you know well we know that
[__] wants his name the rookie is
playing Nathan fill in the greatest man
that ever was
[Applause]
[Music]
have I ever told you my Nathan Fillion
story oh tell me so I uh back when I was
a a journalist for daylight times I got
invited to movie premieres for like a
year it was a glorious year of free food
and shitty booze and uh so I went to
this Captain America Civil War Premiere
okay and I got to take my son who at
that point was like 13 years old to his
first movie premiere and so we're
sitting up in like the second tier of
the of the Dolby Theater no it was like
the show days they went big for [__]
Captain America and so we're sitting
where like
TV stars get to sit the floor is where
movie stars get to sit right so like I'm
like three or four rows behind Nathan
Philly
and so I say hey buddy do you want to go
meet Nathan Fillion he's like who and I
go your mom has a crush on him because
of Castle he's like well then let's make
Mom jealous so we go up to it's like hey
Nathan how are you man he's like Mark
it's good to see you again who's this oh
this is my son Luke and he kneels down
eye to eye and he says Luke I'm a big
fan of your dads
and I was like
[__] you
how dare you unleash such Canadian charm
on my boy who's not ready for it has no
idea how to withstand it and like the
sweetest [__] guy and I hadn't seen
him for like five years and like
remembered my name [__] just being
like blew me up in front of my kid I was
like I can never say a bad thing about
you because you didn't have to do
true I I always remain I ride for people
who are nice when they don't have to be
right and there's no reason for him to
be that [__] kind was this before or
after we had him and Tudyk on the show
um before [__] a before like I
interviewed him once for for
Entertainment Weekly
um when Castle was in its second season
right and like since then every couple
of years we find some way to kind of
glance against each other and all the
time he remembers my name he's always
super [__] kind and so I am eternally
just a joy to watch him [__] live his
dreams he needs to be [__] Green
Lantern he gets me Guy Gardner yes
who gets to be Guy Gardner nobody else
is in the cast
um let's see a woman named Isabella
Merced is playing Hawk Girl Edie gathegi
is playing Mr terrific uh if anybody
watched
um X-Men first Class he played the
unfortunately named Darwin who uh I can
I can adapt to anything except
apparently death
um and uh and there was [__] one more
all right Anthony Kerrigan who was in
Barry yeah do with alopecia yeah yeah is
playing metamorpho oh yeah that's some
good casting yeah and so like Superman
Legacy looks like it's gonna be a
[__] Justice League movie yeah
um I read something where gum was
because people were like what the [__]
where's Superman in this movie he's like
look Superman is more than just Lois and
Perry white and Jimmy Olsen he works
with the Justice League all the time as
well so the idea of him working with
other Heroes I'm here for
um and the last story is a little bit
sad if you were a [__] old school
comic book person as you and I are we
are but uh heavy metal were you a heavy
metal fan of course growing up
absolutely uh drawn nudity is one of my
favorite kinds of nudity in the world
and I love the heavy metal cartoon movie
The Animated feature from years and
years ago that was pretty good uh heavy
metal as a magazine apparently is no
longer in production it is no longer in
publication is that right with issue 320
which apparently uh was supposed to come
out there's supposed to be volume two
number one coming out in early 2023
didn't happen and so the very last issue
of heavy metal is currently on stands
and nobody has any intentions to publish
anymore and that's just kind of [__]
said you know because it has always been
a part of if not my childhood I probably
bought like five or six copies of it but
I just love that it existed I love that
there was an anthology of adult themed
just [__] cartoon assuming some of
the best to ever do it yeah and so that
that's gone and to discover that at
Comic-Con felt a little uh sad cherish
the things you love while they exist
kids there's this feeling that like
it'll always be there and it isn't
always going to be there man let's raise
one up for [__] heavy metal
and go home [__] jerk off to Heavy
Metal One Last Time hey for the kids
just do it for the [__] kids do it
for the kids who won't be able to do it
in the future all right we know we're
supposed to end the show but we
generally end the show with some
questions so let's take at least one
[__] question before we get out of
here and stuff the Tin Roof Inn will
afford us a little more time won't they
yeah they did we just got a thumbs up
well [__] done thank you give it up
for the folks of the tip group
um I mean if you want to do one question
if you wanted to say give that away
that's true man whoever asked the
question is going to walk away with this
50 dollar [__] item right here man no
no gifts this one's mine I I think Brett
deakin showed up with some 4dx tickets
also did he really
is there a 40x in San Diego
that [__] how many we got one set or a
couple sets in here
400 tickets
folks if you've never seen you get a
ticket and you get a ticket everyone
look under your seats if you've never
seen a 40x movie what the [__] are you
waiting for man I don't know if Barbie's
40x but [__] I certainly hope
oppenheimer's not
your chair would [__] explode so it
looks like we got one two three
four
[Music]
five three sets of six
seven eight eight
nine and said Jesus we get to ask
[__] five questions to six six
my math is way wrong yeah strawberry
hurricanes this is my fifth [__]
strawberry hurricane uh all right let's
rapid fire them as and and go through
these 40x questions kids go see a movie
in 40x it's not just a plug because they
give us free tickets it's legitimately
fun they don't do every movie in 40x for
example clerks three never done in 4dx
so much smoke in the theater yes
but there's
there's some 40x man me and Josh went to
see [__] uh Guardians of the Galaxy
and 4dx and dislocated our shoulders
because it jerked us around so [__]
much literally through Dr Josh rash out
of a seat
um so if you if you're near a theater
they've got one in every major city
across America almost check them out the
good folks of 40x all right I'm gonna
let you pick the questions and [__]
because I don't want to get in trouble
all right oh right here
where did the DC EU go wrong not hiring
me and Mark for number one
I'm gonna say they didn't necessarily go
wrong man I you know I I love the
snyderver stuff man it's absolutely
[__] grown on me and stuff and I I
said that I would keep watching Batman v
Superman until I [__] loved it and I
have and I've gotten to a place where I
did I love what Zach did with his corner
of the universe and stuff it reminded me
of the world of comics where sometimes
you get somebody doing a take on the
material that's different from everybody
else's take but just as [__] valid so
I know I don't feel like they went wrong
creatively
financially I can't answer that like at
the end of the day an audience is going
to pick what an audience is going to
pick and most of the DC EU stuff was up
against Marvel at their most [__]
powerful establishing a [__] tone and
stuff and so you'd have people going to
see a Marvel movie but getting a dceu
experience and I guess it wasn't the
same thing for them so my answer is they
didn't go wrong I'm glad those movies
exist and if you love those movies keep
[__] loving them and stuff doesn't
mean just because some people don't feel
the same way you do that it's invalid by
any stretch of the imagination mark
[Laughter]
and now for some Truth by Mark Bernardo
here's here's what I'll say I remember
having uh I I had hired when I was at
the Hollywood Reporter I hired Greg
Rucker to write me a story about
um Superman Man of Steel and the closure
of his story was there should not be a
Superman movie that I cannot take a 15
year old to go see or a 12 year old to
go see like
dark is not always this a solution to
mature and Superman that kills is kind
of a thing that I can't ever really
count Miss and the decision is to do
that I don't understand all of but you
can make a Superman movie where he's
just a [__] good person
you know and unironically good and the
the reason I know that is because they
made a Captain America movie where he's
unironically good there is no jacket and
a gun there is no blinking sideways at
it there's this he's [__] Captain
America and we all bought it and you
could do that with Superman if you
wanted to they just didn't trust it
enough that an audience would roll with
a Superman who found another way to stop
Zod who strapped on that [__] cape
and tights not because his dad told him
not to because his dad told him the
world deserves you Clark you need to go
and be [__] super and so
I think that to a certain degree it was
a little tainted from the root and
everything that sprung out of that was a
little bit not quite right
um there's parts of Man of Steel that I
love but
a kind of weird take on what that
character kind of always has been and
always stood for so that's that's just
where I sit
bam one down there you go man moving on
to the next question JC pick I'll also
say if you want to get your just come up
to me after the show and get your
tickets so we don't if you were the one
that asked the question don't just come
up and ask for [__] tickets
you got to remember the question or
whatever [__] right down here
Mark can you talk about The Distillery
thing since we can see you let's give
you the tickets right here very quickly
Distillery is a brand new comic book
company uh started by the guys in
comicsology Originals
um which I did during the distance
through and their whole plan is to kind
of make big [__] gorgeous comic books
and to empower the creators to
participate in the in the in the
revenues of I I own equity in the
company apparently which is kind of nuts
um and it's a murders of talent it's
like Scott Snyder and job kid me and uh
and and Lee garbett and and Tula wait
what happened to comixology Comics
original still kinds of existed it still
kind of exists hey
but it's kind of not as robust the
publishing experience as it used to be
and the driving forces of It kind of
left and when I started this new thing
and they've got a big booth in the
[__] Comic-Con floor I'm signing over
there tomorrow at noon if you want to
come by and I'll show you what they're
doing it's kind of gorgeous
um so yeah that's distillery in a
nutshell well done well done
go ahead JC we got four more uh at the
bar closest to me
your uh
here one of our Dream characters to
write for in comics that we haven't
already come up and get your tickets
um for me
let's see I wrote for my my dream
character of course was writing for
Batman I got to do that my dream
characters writing for Green Arrow I got
to do that dream character was writing
for Daredevil I got to do that but I've
always wanted to write for the question
I [__] love the questions one of my
favorite titles of all time so one day
hopefully I'll I'll get to do that I
didn't include him in anything I've ever
done before I don't think I've ever
written a word of dialogue for the
question so it'd be nice to be able to
do that eventually you
um one day and one day soon I hope I get
to write Conan the Barbarian
um and I've gotten close once or twice
and sometimes it's Fallen apart because
of my own
um kind of bandwidth availabilities but
Coney the Barbarian is is a is a
foundational character for me
um one might say seminal except I've
never masturbated to it
but yeah knock on wood I'll get to write
this Sumerian before too long
got it done
um all right we've got three more
questions left go
he was very fortunate enough last night
to watch Splinter and now that you're
both directors uh mark what was the
thing that surprised you the most that
Kevin couldn't even prepare you for as
being a director being so close to him
Jesus that's long do it slow I'm [__]
five hurricanes in Mark well don't do
the first part don't do the end mark now
that we're both directors me and Mark
right what was the thing you could not
prepare me for in the experience of
directors copy and there's a part
[__] B to this
what was my feeling when I first saw a
splinter what was my feeling about Mark
as a director copy uh the thing Kevin
could not prepare me for was how
exhausting would be to direct
um it requires like all of your sort of
mental capacity it requires a level of
physical exertion that I didn't know I
had to to put forth because I've watched
him do it but it's you can't know until
you do it
um
but I mean the thing that he told me and
I think excuse me I mentioned it about
it
I just did the same thing
is the like your job as a director is to
make decisions and B keep the mood light
like you're you're throwing a party and
you're hoping that if radio Congress can
have a good time doing it and like I
very much took that to heart
but I had no idea just how [__] tax
it would be to the point where I was
like hey do you want to do this again
it's like not today maybe not this year
maybe not ever and I don't know how one
makes a real movie that takes 30 days to
shoot or a [__] Bond movie that takes
six months to shoot I'm wiped after four
days and so that was the the sort of the
big old [__] he was he's crazy and in
way better shape than I thought he was
thanks
what did I think about when I saw
Splinter I enjoyed the [__] out of it I
was so happy
um that it told a coherent story because
I was like if he [__] this up as the
guy who always shits on everything
[__] like he's gonna have trouble and
[__] but he didn't it was all there and
you could see it and whatnot
um what did I think of him as a director
the the idea that you can bring a vision
to life
like I I think I'm not taking anything
away from directing but I've done it now
for 30 [__] years and I know there
are people that are better at it than me
um and I know there are people that are
not as good as at it as I am and stuff
um that all being said
anybody can [__] direct literally
anybody if you ever spent any moment of
your childhood playing with other people
and being like you say this you stand
here this is what we're doing that's
literally all directing it this is the
playing that you do in childhood done on
an adult level and like he said it's a
job of answering questions as long as
you can answer questions that have fired
at you as rapidly as possible by as many
different sources as possible you can
absolutely Direct that's what it comes
down to people are going like black or
white and you're like oh definitely
[__] black [__] long or short oh
definitely it needs to be short but in
this or that oh it definitely needs to
be that that's basically it because
they're a crew and a cast is trying to
get out of your head a vision that you
have you have the tools and the idea of
directing is communication communicating
those tools to others so that they can
do the thing that you see in your head
if one day we get to a place where we
can cast our thoughts onto some [__]
you know AI screen and [__] AI but if we
could do that and [__] people could
see what's in your head that would be an
easy way to communicate what you dream
about what you see but if you can't do
that in this world this best of all
possible world you can't yet you have to
be able to communicate that idea and get
it across to a bunch of people who are
not inside your head so when I watch
Splinter I understood Mark got that he
was able to communicate what was in his
head and heart to his cast and crew and
they made the thing I'm happy for
anybody when they take their step
forward into a creative world and make
pretend as adults we get to make pretend
as children and it's so [__] fun and
then at some point life forces you to
grow up and get a real job and leave
those things behind and I was a firm
believer in like why you know why do you
have to do that there's this whole
industry and world that is predicated on
[__] dreaming and making pretend so
when I see any adult enter that world or
any [__] kid it makes me happy man
there are two paths in this world that's
it there's creation and [__]
destruction and [__] so the idea of
anyone choosing a creation path just
fills me with [__] Joy because at the
end of the day they're making something
and putting it into the [__] world
not breaking it down and [__]
destroying and [__] on it and
whatnot they're making something
presenting it to the world and
creativity is like it's the only hope
that we [__] have that's where new
ideas come from that's where New Hope
comes from even if you're not a person
who is uh prone to making art or
something like that you are a person
that is informed by art so anytime
anyone makes a step toward creativity I
applaud that 100 when someone you
absolutely love does that and does that
in a way where they're like I wanna I
always wanted to do this before I was
this [__] age and [__] and went out
there and [__] made it happen and
[__] oh I was a bullying as [__] man and
then the fact that it's like I already
support that but that it was good and
[__] watchable and [__] like I got
exactly what was inside his head and
heart made me very [__] happy and
it's sad to hear him say like it's
tiring but like [__] because he
should do it more he sits here every
week and tells a bunch of people that
they're doing their jobs wrong so at the
end of the day the fact that he did his
job right like was proof that he knows
what he's talking about so I hope I know
it's tiring and [__] [__] so tired
but I hope that he does it more before
he leaves this best of all possible
worlds and and for all of that he was
like cut that scene I did I ran away
right away I was like well I mean I'm an
armchair director so I couldn't help but
be like you could lose that you could
lose that I'm more of an armchair editor
than anything yeah is that you cut that
easy trim like four seconds after that a
few seconds after that you go
they call me a director and I'm happy to
accept that title but really I'm more of
an editor I when I shoot on set I'm
constantly editing in my head I'm
constantly I only shoot what I need
anybody who's worked with me will tell
you this I don't overshoot and [__] and
I'm like we'll figure this out in the
editing room [__] I shoot a movie
like a [__] kids puzzle you know some
puzzles like a thousand [__] pieces
and then kids puzzles are like 10
[__] pieces I shoot a movie like a
kid's puzzle which is like I'm only
shooting the pieces I need that are
going to fit together to give you the
picture that's in here and stuff so I'm
never the guy that's like we'll figure
this out later I figured it out on set
that's the indie film mindset we don't
have enough money to figure it out later
on so my instincts all come very
editorially so when I watched it short I
didn't have notes about like oh my God
this is what you could have done as a
directorship my only notes were like
this is what you can lose lose this lose
this lose this and they're [__]
golden and stuff he was almost always
right
all right man those are your tickets we
got two more to go all right heart
attack Jersey
uh pass these tickets back do I feel
worried about the fact go say it again
mama can't be worried about the fact
should Comic-Con be worried about the
fact that Studios one more time
don't see the value of coming to
Comic-Con anymore
um
I don't think studios are ever going to
go away from Comic-Con completely
because at the end of the day it's one
more place to promote and if you're
making a genre film why not [__] come
here so I don't think they'll ever
abandon this place obviously this year
there were plenty of reasons to abandon
this place uh because they didn't have
actors to come and talk about the things
that they were doing and whatnot so I
don't think they're going away
permanently I think it Ebbs and flows I
think there was a period a long stretch
of time where every Studio had to be
here every year in order to remain
relevant and then they figured out that
like you could take your ear off Marvel
took a year off from Hall h before you
know they've taken a year off this year
obviously with the SAG strike and
whatnot but there have been years where
Marvel didn't come here and then they'll
come back the next year they'll come
[__] hard man right in your face neck
and chest so they know the value of this
place but this place does not live and
die by [__] Studios and and their
product this this place has existed for
how many years when did they want what
year
1970s
70s
50. is that right yes because I'm going
to be 53. well then wait how is that
possible 15 almost 53 years so they've
been this Con has been happening for 53
years and it started with a passionate
bunch of individuals who loved [__] that
the world maybe didn't understand now
everyone's on their page they understand
this [__] they understand the value of
it and they inspire a [__] adults to
come to a place and sometimes put on
funny outfits and hang out and talk
about things very passionately that
don't exist in the real world but their
passion brings that [__] very nearly to
[__] life their modern day Geppetto's
at all [__] points who are bringing a
Pinocchio to life just simply by [__]
being here so anybody worth their salt
that is trying to promote a [__]
movie would know that this place is
valuable Hollywood will never [__]
abandon it completely it'll ebb and flow
maybe they've realized they don't need
to do it every [__] year only when
they have something worth bringing to an
event like Comic-Con but Hollywood is
not what necessitates or nor is it the
lifeblood of what this Con is and has
always [__] been it thrives on
[__] passion this room is full of
people who love movies but maybe don't
have anything to do with the movie
industry this Con floor over at [__]
the San Diego Comic-Con looks like this
it's not filled with a bunch of Studio
Executives it's filled with people who
love a [__] thing that they can't
explain to people in their Hometown but
they know that they could come here once
a year and be surrounded by a bunch of
like-minded individuals who feel the
same way they do about unrealistic [__]
so at the end of the day Hollywood is
not we're not dependent on Hollywood at
this time they're welcome always [__]
welcome and stuff because we love the
things they make and stuff maybe not
this year because we're striking but
generally speaking we love what they
make we're part of the Dream Factory
we're partner the audience we're part of
the makers of those things sometimes so
they have a place at this table but they
do not set this [__] table fandom
sets this [__] table and always will
yeah
uh nothing further counselor
Bam Bam fans in the house everybody go
ahead Batman I'll I'll add something uh
when I made scum and villainy the dream
was to create the Comic-Con bar nice not
like the after party right because
that's what you remember when you go
home to wherever you're going is the
night you spent talking to the person
you didn't know about what you saw you
don't really remember what you saw you
remember the people that you met so
Comic-Con isn't about Studios or what
you bought or who you saw or what
autograph you got it's about community
and as long as people show up like it'll
be fun
one of the greatest give it up for that
is beautiful
one of the greatest movie-going
experiences of my entire [__] life
and I say that as a person who has
watched movies his entire [__] life
and now owns a [__] movie theater
that's how much I believe in the craft
and the art form I went to see this
movie I don't know if everybody ever saw
it but it's called The Dark Knight and I
was invited there by Peter sharetta who
used to run slash film and I went with a
couple of uh they were journalists you
know film journals and stuff and had
movie websites and whatnot and Peter's
like hey I got tickets to this thing you
want to go I said absolutely I love The
Dark Knight it's an amazing [__]
movie but my memories of The Dark Knight
aside from the movie itself extend to
the conversation that we had for an hour
and a half after that movie ended
outside of the [__] theater I still
think about it to this day as we sat
there and dissected this [__] movie
which like transcended the art form at
that point where suddenly we were like
watching this [__] movie where I said
it that day like in the parking lot I
was like this is the Godfather II of
[__] comic book movies man it took
this [__] so seriously it transcended
the conversations that we had in that
parking lot to me are as meaningful as
watching the movie was so that's all a
part of everybody being involved it's
not just watching the [__] thing it's
the conversations that we have after the
[__] thing that matters just as much
as watching the [__] thing and that's
always what this podcast was supposed to
be yes that's always how we described it
was this is the conversation you have
after seeing a movie that you love or
hate and you're hanging on the parking
lot before you get in your cars and go
home yes that's all this ever was two
guys who love movies who just want to
talk about
all right I don't know if my Math's
correct because I'm [__] wasted is
this uh the last one to go uh Wonder
Woman right here
I've talked about wearing many hats in
my life a director writer exhibitor
podcast or so forth and so forth and so
forth welcome
do I have a favorite hat and why
um what a great [__] question
I'm trying to think if I have a favorite
hat
Ben
maybe it because at the end of the day
that's at the root of [__] it thank you
thank you for thinking for a drunk man
at the root of everything I do is a
passion for it That Grew From fandom you
don't
can't be it unless you see it first and
what I saw is my entire life as a fan
and that life has extended up until this
[__] moment right now was what I
wanted to be and [__] do the
possibility of who I can be based on
what I [__] watched so I didn't
become a director because I was the
first person that discovered directing I
became a director because I saw other
people do it because at a young age I
realized there was somebody behind the
movies they didn't just [__] happen
somebody had a vision and brought that
[__] to life I became a writer
because I understood at a young age that
somebody had to create these [__]
words and stick them into the mouths of
actors I became an actor because it
looked [__] fun I became a podcaster
because like I listened to Howard Stern
as a kid who sat around with his friends
and [__] had conversations for four
hours [__] every weekday morning and
I was like what a great way to live that
would [__] be there's always somebody
doing a thing that I look at and be like
that seems [__] fun I would like to
try that so I think you're absolutely
right thank you for thinking for me when
I can't think anymore
I think at the root of everything I do
is being a [__] fan and so I think
wearing the fan hat it's the most
comfortably everything else I could be
criticized as I could be criticized as a
filmmaker I could be criticized as a
writer and I assure you I've been
criticized as [__] bull somehow
they've criticized me as a [__]
podcaster as well and stuff anything I
choose to do and got paid for a
professionally I could be criticized for
but nobody can criticize you as a fan
because you love what you [__] love
so I agree with them the fan hack is the
one that fits [__] best I've said it
for years I was a member of the audience
before anything else before I became a
maker or anything like that I was a
member of the audience and one day that
is where I will go back to that is where
I will retire to because maybe one day
I'll grow out of wanting to do a thing
maybe [__] the audience will beat me
down to the point of like I don't want
to make a [__] thing anymore but
nobody will ever take me away from
[__] the joy of watching the [__]
thing appreciating a thing losing myself
for a half an hour one hour two hours in
[__] make believe or a whole season
of [__] make-believe I started as a
fan I'll die a [__] fan I'm a fan
right [__] now so
uh the hat that I feel most comfortable
at home in
um I think it's it's uh apparent
I think and and parent not just for my
own children because whatever like I
have to I suppose legally by law the
government will come for me if I'm
shitty
but I think it's the thing that as a as
a parent you want to be able to do right
it's and the role of a parent which is
not just a teach which is not just to
help counsel and guide and all that [__]
but if you're a good parent you learn as
much from your kids as you as you help
teach them something
and to always like it's about caring
it's about giving of yourself before you
give to yourself it's about sharing the
things that you love with the people
that you are the closest to
um and it's wishing well even if you can
no longer have any control over you know
I mean when I when I see people in the
world whether I know them or I don't
know them the thing that I say instead
of goodbye is be good
okay be good and it's not because I'm
like why am I crying am I drunk you are
and I saw I heard your voice cracking I
was like he's gonna [__] cry
do it do it let it spill as a guy who
cries on the internet for a living do it
do it
it feels good it does feel good it's
cathartic
you're going to be called a soy boy but
whatever the [__]
but it's it's
find a way to have Grace in the world
and be kind to each other be good to
each other
so when you leave tonight as you walk
into the Gaslamp and Dodge like you know
[__] bachelorette parties and
Klingons and all that [__]
good to yourself be good to each other
be good to this place be good to fandom
be good to the [__] you love and uh and
be good to us
because why not [__] uh give it up
for Mark Bernard
ladies and gentlemen you have been
forced to sit with two drunk middle-aged
men
and their passions and feelings y'all
have a good time tonight
thank you
for those of you who are sticking around
to take pictures with us we'll be doing
it upstairs in a few minutes they'll
line you up and tell you where to go if
you're like what the [__] we can take
pictures with those crying [__] and
[__] you can sign up right here if you
want to join us and stuff like that but
by first and most important question is
kids have you had a good time
if you did man we have a couple people
to thank give it up for the good folks
who hosted the movies pop up the Tin
Roof Inn
fan himself JC
give it up for Dr Josh Roush she made
sure you could see us at home
wrong reasons coming out [__]
mid-august kids get it [__] that's
Josh's movie and give it up for the man
the crybaby next to me
Mark [__] Bernardin
thank you
and that lady gentlemen kids of all ages
is fat man beyond for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I'm a crying [__]
help tune in next time same fat Time
same fat channels podcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith a Comic-Con
Jeff's kiss to all of you
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
foreign